how many of you know cpr in case of an
emergency an important time for adults
to take that refresher course says the
u.s consumer product safety commission
their latest drowning data shows an
increase in child drownings of kids
under the age of 15 between the years of
2016
and 2018. drownings are preventable and
the pandemic forcing closures prevented
many families from signing their kids up
for the swim lessons
nikki fleming says kids should be
getting refresher swim lessons
parents refresh your cpr courses as well
as making sure you have plenty of safety
barriers in place
the key to prevention is multiple layers
of protection not just one
so a four-sided four-foot fence with a
self-closing self-latching gate
in addition you want to also have a pull
alarm a door alarm
even a pool cover any additional
physical berries
between your child and the water and she
says always designate a water watcher
for your children if you're hosting a
party hire a lifeguard from the local
ymca or community center